[Music]
on this Wednesday night new allegations
against a sitting liberal MP Han Dong's
alleged push to delay the release of the
two Michaels a global news exclusive
Donald Trump's legal drama he hasn't
been arrested but now his lawyer is told
to hand over evidence very serious very
unusual
zielinski on the front lines the
Ukrainian president's message as the
leaders of Russia and China show
solidarity
National
thanks for joining us we begin tonight
with more allegations about a liberal MP
who National Security sources tell
Global News was in contact with the
Chinese Consul General in Toronto in
2021. Han dong and Ontario MP is the
politician who National Security
officials allegedly briefed senior aides
to the Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
about before the 2019 election warning
them dong was believed to be part of a
Chinese foreign interference Network
dong denies the allegations now global
news has learned about a conversation
Han dong had with a Chinese Diplomat
about the two Michaels while they were
still being held in a Chinese jail
Mackenzie gray has our top story tonight
in February 2021 Michael kovrig and
Michael spavor had been detained in a
Chinese prison for nearly 800 days but
while they languished away Ontario
liberal MP Han dong allegedly advised a
top Chinese Diplomat to hold off on
immediately freeing them two independent
National Security sources have told
global news that dog spoke with China's
Consular General in Toronto Han Tao and
suggested to him that a Beijing released
the two Michaels then Federal
conservatives would benefit how exactly
is not clear dong allegedly initiated
the discussion with the consul General
where he also allegedly recommended that
Beijing offers some show of progress
with the two Michael's cases to help
benefit the Liberals according to the
two sources don't confirm to global news
that the conversation took place but he
denied he initiated the discussion and
says that he advocated for the two
Michaels to be set free at every
opportunity before they returned home I
adamantly demanded their released to
Canada without delay said dong any
suggestions otherwise are false and our
attempts to mislead you your readers and
slander me the two Michaels had been
jailed in apparent retribution for
Canada's Detention of Huawei executive
Mong Wang Zhou but at the time of Dong's
conversation with the Chinese Diplomat
the Prime Minister had publicly been
calling for their release this is an
issue that is a top priority for us as a
country to secure the release of
Michael's favor Michael kovrick
Trudeau's office says the Prime Minister
only learned of the conversation with
the Chinese Envoy after dong told pmo
but dong only informed the prime
minister's team after global news
reached out for comment as a Chinese
Canadian I am so proud a national
security official told global news that
by the time the alleged conversation in
February 2021 took place cesus had
already classified dong as a close
friend of the consulate based on his
history of calls but they had also
considered if dong was acting as to back
Channel interlocutor between the
Canadian and Chinese governments the pmo
denied that theory saying at no time was
Mr dong ever used as a back Channel
Global News has not been able to
independently verify what was said in
the communication between dong and the
consul General
last month Global News reported that
dong allegedly received help from the
Chinese Consulate in Toronto during his
2019 liberal nomination meeting in Dawn
Valley North allegations dong denies
because of the news story and all the
hateful uh aggressive comments
death threats come my way it does impact
constitutions in my right we reached out
to ceases for comment on the dawn
conversation a spokesperson for the
agency said they can neither confirm nor
deny the authenticity of the information
Donna all right Mackenzie gray and
Ottawa thanks there is more legal drama
over former president Donald Trump who
said last week he expected to be
arrested he has not been arrested but
throughout the night and into today
legal arguments have been flying back
and forth over whether Trump's own
lawyer has to provide testimony and
evidenced prosecutors because his
Services may have been used to
facilitate a possible crime Jackson
crosco is in Manhattan tonight Jackson
this is an unexpected twist how serious
is it
very serious Donna in fact late today a
panel of three judges ruled that Trump's
attorney Evan Corcoran must appear
before a grand jury and provide evidence
to them as early as Friday this is the
grand jury investigating the classified
documents found at Trump's Mar-A-Lago
home in Florida and it is a very serious
development because what the judges have
done is break attorney-client privilege
here they've done so because they
believe Trump has committed a crime and
has lied to his own attorneys about it
and there is what's known as a crime
fraud exception in attorney-client
privilege and that is why Mr Corcoran
will be compelled to testify and produce
evidence this is arguably a nightmare
scenario for someone in Mr Trump's
position a potential defendant who is
under criminal investigation
this means that the lawyer will have to
testify we'll turn over documents that
reflect the legal advice in the back and
forth that he was having with President
Trump again very unusual uh for a
federal judge to determine that a client
was apparently using a lawyer in
furtherance of a crime or a fraud it's
not something that happens every day
it's very serious and very unusual
well Jackson the lawyers sure are busy
what happens next
well the work of a grand jury typically
remains secret so we won't know more
until things either appear on a court
docket somewhere or an announcement is
made by prosecutors but we do know that
in the Mar-A-Lago documents case things
are moving very very rapidly at this
point under the supervision of that
special counsel back in Washington
meanwhile back here in New York the
grand jury that is continuing to look at
the 2016 alleged hush money payments to
adult film star Stormy Daniels did not
convene today the grand jury was told to
stay home it's not clear why they are on
standby to meet again tomorrow and Donna
it is very possible that at that meeting
tomorrow they could in fact vote to
indict former president Donald Trump
making him the first former American
president to of course face indictments
and arrest
watching Jackson prosco in New York
tonight thanks interest rates in the U.S
went up a notch today the U.S federal
reserve raised The Benchmark rate by a
quarter point to the highest level since
October 2007. it is the ninth
consecutive rate hike intended to slow
spending and inflation by increasing the
cost of borrowing the rate hike was half
of what economists had expected in a
statement the U.S federal reserve says
the country's banking system is sound
and resilient but says recent banking
failures could result in tighter credit
conditions for households and businesses
Canada welcomes the American president
for an official visit Joe Biden arrives
tomorrow and one of the issues expected
to be on the agenda is Haiti there are
reports Biden is pressuring Canada to
lead an International Security Force to
try to quell the extreme gang-led
violence in Haiti as Mike Armstrong
reports the U.N has called for a
specialized support force and in the
meantime it's the Haitian people who are
suffering
there is something you see in images of
Haiti's violence as gangs face off with
police or other gangs the public runs
from the gunfire refugee camps are
growing as an estimated 160 thousand
people have been forced from their homes
to escape gang violence
this woman says her home was invaded by
gangs her husband was killed but she's
living with five children in hunger and
misery
more than 530 people have been killed in
gang violence according to the UN just
since January 1st but there's also an
escalation more than 200 of those deaths
came just since the beginning of this
month
un deployed a seven-member mission to
Haiti last month to survey the situation
when she describes what she saw there
was an exasperation in osnot librani's
voice there's even the sense that as
worse as it is now it can get even worse
now 80s acting prime minister called for
international intervention five months
ago some sort of military force to
stabilize the country there is support
from the U.N but there's no consensus
from Haitians themselves critics point
to failed interventions in the past that
weakened the country instead of helping
any International force will not be able
to bring stability Matthias Pierre is
the former director of Elections Haiti
he says needs support but not soldiers
there's also a catch-22 many Haitians
question the legitimacy of the acting
prime minister calling for the
intervention Ariel Ari wasn't elected he
got the job after the assassination of
the president not having election not
having a legitimate government is
fueling also the insecurity problem
both Brazil and Canada have been talked
about as front-runners to lead a
stabilization Force but both are
reluctant getting involved would mean
not months but likely years it would put
soldiers in danger and gang leaders warn
would put civilians in the middle again
Mike Armstrong Global News
Canada is extending the emergency visa
application deadline for ukrainians
fleeing the war to July 15th the program
that expedites visas and temporary
residency permits was set to expire next
Friday
we've been able to help significantly
larger numbers of people than what have
otherwise been the case I'm actually
quite uh pleased with the results
despite some lessons we've learned along
the way because we now have a model that
can offer temporary protection uh where
it did not exist before
ukrainians have until March 31st 2024 to
arrive in Canada under the program they
can stay up to three years they're also
eligible for a one-time income support
payment and temporary accommodations
nearly 191
000 ukrainians have arrived since
January of 2022. Russian President
Vladimir Putin has wrapped up talks with
his Chinese counterpart in Moscow
the two authoritarian leaders said warm
goodbyes at the Kremlin she told Putin
there are changes that haven't happened
in 100 years and we together he said are
driving those changes the two pledged to
bolster strategic ties there was no
breakthrough though on ending the war in
Ukraine Ukraine's President Vladimir
zielinski was close to the front lines
today visiting troops near bakmut where
fighting is raged for months he honored
soldiers there with medals and he vowed
Ukraine will respond to every blow after
a new wave of deadly airstrikes Crystal
gemancing Reports
filled by China as a journey of
friendship cooperation and peace the two
dear friends as they described
themselves wrapped up a state visit with
a warm goodbye and talk of Russia and
China being the driving forces behind
changes not seen in 100 years
Russia's interpretation of the visit
summed up in one headline reading guest
from heaven in Ukraine where Russia
wages its brutal War a hellish morning
two nine-story residential buildings
were hidden a strike in the city of
zaparizia at least 30 people were
injured and one person killed it was
captured on surveillance video 13 months
on Ukraine's president took to social
media writing these strikes should not
become just an ordinary day in Ukraine
the United States had urged Chinese
president Xi Jinping to persuade Russia
to quote halt the war crimes China's
foreign Ministry spokesperson pushed
back today
asking is it fair to push the conflict
towards escalation with spillover
effects on the worlds the state visit
did not result in any peace deal
developments the two did sign bilateral
trade deals cementing future
cooperations and sectors such as
Agriculture and Technology Far From Any
pomp or ceremony Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski spent Wednesday
touring the Donetsk region surprise
soldiers at a gas station snapped photos
the president spent time shaking hands
and handing out medals in a hospital and
at a location identified only as being
in the direction of buckmut an Eastern
hotbed of deadly fighting the visit no
doubt Ukraine's way of showing the world
its troops are holding steady Crystal
commencing Global News London
former British prime minister Boris
Johnson was back in the spotlight today
defending himself against accusations he
lied to Parliament about parties held in
government buildings during the covid-19
lockdown
I'm here to say to you hand on heart
that I did not lie to the house when
those statements were made they were
made in good faith and on the basis of
what I honestly knew and believed at the
time
when this inquiry was set up I was
completely confident that you would find
nothing to show I knew or believed
anything else as indeed you have not
Johnson was grilled at a committee over
the so-called party Gate scandal and
whether he intentionally misled
Parliament he says the parties were
necessary for work purposes if the
committee finds he deliberately lied it
could potentially lead to his suspension
or even losing his seat
avoiding tragedy on the high seas coming
up a call for more stringent safety laws
after six crew members died in a sinking
of Nova Scotia
the Transportation safety board has
released the results of their
investigation into the sinking of the
Nova Scotia scallop fishing boat in 2020
it capsized in the Bay of fun day in all
six crew members on board died today's
report suggests important safety
procedures that were overlooked could
have prevented the tragedy Alicia drows
explains
anger is one of the biggest ones to know
that this could have possibly been
prevented Michelle Nickerson forbes's
former spouse Dan Forbes never came home
he was on board the Chief William Solace
it capsized in strong winds on its way
to port in Digby Nova Scotia on December
15 2020. the report on the capsizing
says 2 700 kilograms of scallop were
stacked almost two meters high on the
deck something that likely contributed
to the boat's instability potentially
blocking drainage Transport Canada does
not require stability assessments for
smaller vessels unless they've had major
modifications which was the case with
the Chief William Solace however that
rule didn't come into effect until three
months after the vessel's last
inspection in April 2017. Transport
Canada didn't require didn't request or
require
the operator the owner to to do a
stability assessment and without that
stability ability assessment the crew
was unaware of the safe operating limits
the report also found the vassal did not
have adequate written safety procedures
on board with no specifics for how
scallop bestowed the Transportation
safety board now recommending each
inspection of a commercial fishing
vessel verifies written safety
procedures are available to the crew and
that the crew know the procedures
Nickerson Forbes says recommendations
don't go far enough especially
considering the TSB had previously
recommended stability assessments be
required for all vessels following the
Fatal capsizing of a boat off the coast
of BC in 2015. we are really really
hoping that we can change
recommendations and at some point make
our government realize that
recommendations don't go anywhere but
laws do Alicia drows Global News Halifax
allergy season ahead why some Canadians
diagnosed with asthma aren't getting the
medication they need
spring is always welcome after a long
winter but for people with asthma it
also means bracing for allergies a new
study suggests Canadians diagnosed with
asthma aren't always getting the
medication they need Catherine Ward
looks into that
more people are being diagnosed with
this disease the amount of medications
that they're using didn't really change
over that course of the 12 years that's
a troubling pattern for Dr Mohit bhutani
and his research team Alberta data shows
asthma patients are not getting
prescriptions filled patients who have
were diagnosed with asthma on average
were only getting up to maximum of three
months of medications being dispensed
per year a lot of people unfortunately
understandably but they might not want
to fully deal with having a chronic
condition a lot of people think asthma
uh apologies as well are episodic but
they're not they're chronic
experts say not having the medication on
hand particularly during allergy season
can be a challenge
eighty percent of people that have
asthma also suffer from allergic
rhinitis for many patients with asthma
they may have environmental allergies
and if those allergies include pollen
for example in the spring or the summer
then their asthma may be more of a
problem through those months
research team says there are many
reasons why a prescription might not get
filled that could include doctors not
prescribing the right medication
patients not understanding how and when
to use what's been given to them or
simply the associated cost for others
access to care is a barrier that they
don't have a family doctor they may not
be able to get that renewal but others
choose to live with the condition and
adapt their behavior which experts don't
recommend we find that you know that
asthmatics tend to live with the lower
quality of life and have more absentee
days from school or from work and so you
know it's concerning because asthmatic
patients could live a better life
Catherine Ward Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
here in Canada is naramata BC thanks for
watching bye-bye